je m'appelle laurent pineau j'ai 37 ans
et je suis pâtissier depuis
plus de 20 ans et là on est actuellement
dans mon laboratoire donc j'ai créé mon
entreprise il ya six ans la cour tenait
dans les ports du loiret
quand j'étais jeune la première
sensation qui a vraiment validé aussi le
fait de devenir pâtissier c'est quand je
suis arrivé le premier jour j'ai mon
premier emploi hier à 6 heures du matin
dans la rue de la boulangerie où on
sentait déjà les odeurs de croissants
qui était au four et le pain qui se
remettait toujours là j'ai tout de suite
senti que c'est ce qu'ils allaient
vraiment me me passionner toute ma vie
[Musique]
et
la pâtisserie c'est une mode c'est une
mode on un climat l'été où ça devient
vraiment très chaud très lourd donc à la
fin d'un repas on est obligé de proposer
alors aujourd'hui à un client un gâteau
qui sera très fondant très léger en
bouche et très frais donc là c'est le
gâteau signature de la boutique c'est un
gâteau que j'ai créée pour l'ouverture
de la boutique
il s'appelle le tentation donc c'est un
gâteau qui a 5 6 couches différentes
il m'a demandé à peu près six mois de
travail pour arriver à trouver un
équilibre parfait entre le côté sucré et
le côté acidulé du citron on a le
biscuit aux amandes une fine couche de
compotée de framboises maison ensuite
c'est parsemé d'un petit peu d'éclat de
fèves de cacao pour donner un côté
croquant vos gâteaux une ganache
crémeuse au chocolat ambrée et une
mousse légère au citron jaune avec ds de
combat va
[Musique]
boutique c'est essentiellement donc
70 % c'est la pâtisserie et pâtisseries
le pur fabriquer 100 % maison après on a
de la confiserie on a des chocolateries
qui qui est une une grosse partie des
ventes aussi la chocolaterie et on
trouve aussi un petit peu du lasri je
suis glaciers aussi de deux formations
donc là je suis en train de doré la
viennoiserie donc c'est une viennoiserie
100% fait-maison pur beurre beurre aop
[Musique]
une petite pâtisserie pur par rapport à
un boulanger je passe moins de deux
lilloises riz c'est pas vraiment le
point clé de la boutique mais je veux
apporter un bon croissant avec un bon
goût et montrer qu'on peut vraiment
faire
de vrais viennoiseries
avec énormément de gaulle et de qualité
[Musique]
une pâtisserie pur on va vraiment être à
la recherche d'un gâteau bien défini on
va essayer de créer une émotion chez le
client des sensations gustatives des
gâteaux qui sont plus travaillés moins
sucré plus léger donc c'est vrai que
céder le produit d'appel c'est le pain
donc la facilité c'est d'avoir des
boulangeries et une bonne pâtisserie
pour moi c'est ça reste quand même
essentiel parce qu'on va beaucoup plus
rentrer dans les détails du gâteau de la
confiserie ou du chocolat bonne journée
à vous en remerçie d'avoire bientôt